you could binge watch the entire first
season of afterlife
instead of watching this show that
that's a show about a man
who wants to kill himself because his
wife dies of cancer
and it's still more fun than this okay
spoiler alert um season two is on the
way so in the end
he obviously didn't kill himself just
like jeffrey epstein
shut up i know he's your friend but i
don't care
[Applause]
do you like to make your own way here in
your own plane didn't you this is a big
week for
uh for that nirvana for nirvana with 20
years
yeah anniversary whatever happened to
the the naked kid on the cover of that
album
i assume you got into porn did you ever
meet kurt cobain
i don't i'm not i don't know why i look
at child porn but i'm so glad they're
getting
your friend jeff jeff epstein speaking
of porn jeff platt
what's that oh epstein that jeff epstein
that guy's no good
and i know uh i know uh rich
you know people that get a lot of money
that makes you good but
he seems to uh real uh scumbag if you
will
well if the allegations are true
apparently he took a a group of
very young girls and then he made them
the sexual play things for me i mean
this guy was a real
jerk yeah real there ought to be a
lawyer
i'm gonna need everybody here to lower
their expectations uh
it's a tuesday we're gonna roll in today
how old are you guys
[Applause]
let me ask you a question
how is jeffrey epstein's highlight
how old are you 18 you're aged out
hey look at you on that island like what
this old [ __ ] doing over here
get her ass out of here you got your
period [ __ ] out of here
guys
can i tell you guys a story okay
last night
i'm doing a show here okay
and i was talking about the abstain
thing
and two people a couple just get up and
they [ __ ] leave
just trying to come up with an epstein
joke right because how do you justify
what he's doing it's [ __ ] horrible
right
so i'm just talking about it last night
on stage i'm just bringing it up
i know it's bad okay but i'm just
throwing ideas out there
just throwing them out just jokes
you know i'm like the reason why he had
the young girls
on the island is because in case they
tried to
swim away he would just play
baby
daddy just kidding they don't have dads
look
that's why they were on the island guys
i'm just searching for jokes here
i know it's [ __ ] up sir okay
you look like you've been
[Music]
you look like the contractor that built
that island
listen if you want a good dungeon what
you got to do
let's see let me tell you something let
me tell you you want a dungeon i'll
teach you how to make a dungeon
let's see oh you got a good oak
you go 20 feet under the ground plaster
it all
up okay the girl screams can't get
through the plaster
look i'm just throwing the idea it
doesn't matter
the couple gets up and they [ __ ] run
out
they run the [ __ ] out and i stop and
instead of making fun of
anything i was like listen they did the
exact right thing
they did the exact right thing they felt
uncomfortable
they felt you know wildly miserable
and they were in an awful situation and
then they just got up
and left right
now the tricky thing about being on an
[Music]
island
you won't be here for a while
hey my name is tommy delvecchio de
benedetto and i was uh jerry epstein's
security guard at the metropolitan
detention center a lot of people on
online are trying to pin this on the
[ __ ] clintons
let me tell you man they're good [ __ ]
people they love this guy
they visited them three times this week
in the middle of the [ __ ] night
because they didn't want to make a big
deal out of it
because they're [ __ ] humble you
should have seen hillary clinton when
she saw him
it was like a [ __ ] dog that had just
you know when her owners in iraq and he
comes back
she just [ __ ] lunged at him she went
right for him i had to [ __ ] pull her
off him she was so [ __ ] excited
they [ __ ] loved each other sometimes
that's what happens on suicide watch
people commit suicide that's why they
call suicide watch
the clinton's man they gave a [ __ ] about
this guy
they're like a [ __ ] family i mean the
night he died they were here praying
with him they looked like they were
drinking like
wine or some dark red liquid in a
chalice and they were all [ __ ]
chanting in the cell together
it was [ __ ] beautiful i didn't even
know why i was [ __ ] in here
i thought it was like he hired some
illegals you know because he's got like
an all-inclusive in the bahamas
but my friend said he had underage girls
in there and i said you know my cousin
had that [ __ ] problem
but you know what he did he found a girl
that looked young but was really old as
[ __ ]
you know those girls that like look 14
but they're 40.
you go and see their face it's like real
rough the skin by the creases of their
mouth is like raw
but you know you're not [ __ ] with you
donna you know i [ __ ] love you
you saved that man's life
he wasn't a bad dude jerry epstein you
know he's not a bad [ __ ] dude
[Music]
jesus you know what this reminds me of
what about that [ __ ] i didn't even
pay attention to that guy that [ __ ]
billionaire
pedophile with his own [ __ ] island
that sounds like a cheesy b
movie i can't believe that was actually
real this guy doesn't even
gets put in [ __ ] jail [ __ ] time
and spends 12 hours a day in his own
[ __ ] mansion
that's unreal you know if i ran jails by
the way as much as i'm into punishing
people i would stop
short of no [ __ ]
that's where i would draw the line okay
you want to incarcerate somebody blah
blah blah and all that type of [ __ ]
but you know there's clearly plenty of
women out there that really
are into guys that are into jail so why
not bring them in
once every once a day you haven't come
in there you
[ __ ] them you keep everybody relaxed
and then that's then you're fine no more
riots no more
rape and [ __ ] you know some
accountant
whose wife asked for too much [ __ ]
alimony and he snapped
and he grabbed something that they got
together at the epcot center that used
to that used to represent their love
and now represents their divide and he
decided to smash it and he accidentally
killed her and he feels bad
and he wouldn't kill anybody else he's
not a killer it's just a passionate
a moment of passion he's not going to
kill anybody else unless he gets married
again and she asked for too much money
during the divorce settlement right he's
that kind of a killer
okay he's like the killing
he's the murdering equivalent of that
guy who his team is down
17-8 two outs down to the last strike
and he's still sitting there keeping
score in the [ __ ] sun
when everybody else left passion
anyways you know so then that guy goes
to jail and now he's getting raped
[ __ ] seven ways to sunday
and just you know if you just [ __ ]
went out there and you got those [ __ ]
lunatics
a little bit of ass a couple times a
week why does it have to be straight
across the board
punishment you're keeping people calm
you're making the judge the
the the [ __ ] the uh the guys who
worked there what are you calling there
the assistants the matadors what do you
call the [ __ ] people of the guards
jesus christ i can't even think today
i'm matadors
yeah you making their job easy
everybody's getting laid everybody's
[ __ ] fine
you know
be the easiest warden ever
second there was a riot i'd just be on
the bullhorn like excuse me
yeah what what exactly is the problem
did the cincinnati please explain to me
what the problem is a free roaming board
and you're getting [ __ ] six times a
week
that's right it is a good deal all right
well put down the sharpened toothbrush
all of you thank you then they go back
to their cells that's right the ward's a
good guy
i know you're supposed to punish people
but you know what i mean you're also
you know getting everybody all [ __ ]
pent up i mean i know they've made a
whole [ __ ] channel out of it well
now you now you can't turn you can't
turn it back because they got they they
literally have a whole [ __ ] network
they they one of those channels is
essentially the prison riot channel
right
i left behind the bar san quentin they
do all that [ __ ] what the tattoos mean
over here is the latino section
over here is the white section it's
always all these neo-nazis right
over here is the black section
and everybody's gotta [ __ ] explain
stuff see as a white guy i'm not allowed
to go over yeah i would assume that
dude be honest with yourself there's a
white suburban guy like myself how big
of a [ __ ] nazi would you become the
second you joined you got into prison
you just have to do it in order to
survive
i mean how progressive are you that
you're gonna take a
gang raping in your ass
you know i mean would you rather do that
or just [ __ ]
just you know just kind of go hey you
know white power you know with the same
enthusiasm you do
when someone does the wave when you go
to a baseball game and someone gets the
wave going and you're just [ __ ] sick
of it 30 years of doing it but you know
if you're with somebody's new you
bring your nephew there hey you [ __ ]
get white power
white power i don't want to get raped
god bless hitler keep your dick out of
my ass you do whatever that body
language looks like i'm sure there's
some psychiatrists out there that can
tell you what that looks like
all right jesus christ how did we get
here